hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Fran bow now when we
last left off we were in this room and
we were exploring a bunch of food items
and we did get something from the girl
which is a magic sleeping pill but I
don't exactly know who I need to give
that to just yet unless I need to give
it to the guard who is guarding the key
and then I would be able to get the key
from him because if he needed anything
say a cup of coffee ah there was a cup
of coffee in this other room over here
okay peace in things to get don't just
stand at the door like a creeper get
actually get in there okay so if I
examine this magical stuff to make
anyone fall asleep so if I use this on
that won't work oh but I had an idea
fine
hello let's see hello how are you doing
oh hello Fran how are you today I see
dead animals that'd probably be
something I should probably tell the
nursing staff you mean in the television
no for real I mean for real just forget
it
whatever very well Fran go play with
your friends now not that you care about
our situation at all
fine okay so there's got to be another
place that I can put the sleeping bill
that would be advantageous to my
survival maybe I could figure out or
maybe this kid wants it maybe there's
alternate routes that I need to do
things nothing of course what was I
thinking
okay so there's got to be something to
that I know there's got to be someone
that I could make fall asleep so that I
can get something from them it just made
sense to me that it would be the person
out here if I didn't need the key but
that would be the key to get outside and
I'm guessing that getting outside isn't
just the first thing that I need to do
does that sound okay so I'm gonna take a
pill again hello goodbye okay so I need
to get two things for the UH I need to
get two things for the dude for the King
okay
so as soon as I get the two things that
I need for the King then I'll be able to
do what I need to do to continue on the
game whoa
I don't reach the key well that's what
I'd like to do Oh God
wonder what part of the body that is not
the good part mr. pig is naked he's more
than just naked a crunchy pigs had ready
to be served why is it crunchy why does
it have to be crunchy little girl okay
so I need to reach the key that's
obvious um but to be able to reach the
key I need to get around that guard whoa
was that there before I don't think I
came through here with the pill just yet
uh-oh this clock sounds odd
it also looks a little weird but I'm not
gonna be too worried about that just yet
come on bear miss a bleeding clock it's
with all the kinks your dress is very
pretty
my mother had a very pretty dress too
okay so I gotta find something else out
here hello how's it going again I'm
gonna cap off and pills for now and then
wander the area okay because I know that
on the message it said that the King
likes to draw but I can't get the
crayons because she won't give them to
me and in other news he wants a horse
head now there is a horse head here now
would I be able to get the horse head
from something else to be able to use it
on the horse no I'm not okay so I gotta
be able to do some okay let me think
about this for a second I'll be right
back
okay take a pill maybe maybe I could
back and forth a trip of our lives
aha okay so if you wanna do I'm good
night or a horse and that might be an
option but I don't know how to get that
to him and this in a year said that the
King likes to draw so didn't oh oh
that's right I didn't actually pick up
the paper from the other guy so if I oh
that was right I never picked up the
paper so that's part of it so I need the
paper to be able to draw something on
and maybe that would be good enough
because if I get oh if I get the paper
and then I give it to the girl who likes
to draw then she has something she wants
to draw on there we go okay now I can
write her drawn when I'm bored okay so
if I take this to the girl that likes to
draw maybe she could draw him oh hey
what are you doing here okay bye what oh
oh
okay where are you going this really
weird that's the girl that gave me the
pill but what is she doing
where's she going and why do they let
the kids just wandering around in this
you know asylum of things I'm gonna
follow her for a little bit because it's
just a little bizarre I mean this is
obviously leading me somewhere right it
has to be there's no way it's not
oh hi what what are you doing now hello
hi oh come on that was so leading me
somewhere that was so leading me some
okay whatever never mind okay so I have
the paper now that I can get to this the
girl so if I give the paper to this girl
then she should be able to yeah use
white paper with trying out things is
good but in this case it won't do any
good okay so if I try it on the crayons
maybe wink ah come on
but that's so oh I thought that was
gonna be what it was
oh please cure me and stop the red milk
see what I can do god damn it I thought
I was honest I thought I felt so smart I
felt so smart oh okay I took a cinnamon
bun oh okay then so oh okay I didn't
know that I could grab one of these okay
so maybe if I combine that with yes okay
a sleepy cake so now I can give this to
the guy and then I can get the key and
then I can get into the reception area
hopefully that's what's this is leading
do okay I knew it had to be something
would you like a cinnamon bun I brought
this cake for you I don't want any
trouble so I brought this cake for you
I'm not interested in taking anything
that comes from you make your life
through please take it it will make your
life a bit sweeter I don't care about
making my life sweeter now leave you
don't so you don't want it no now leave
me alone well what a jerk
what a little jerk who can I give this
to I guess I could give it to the little
girl and then steal her crayons stop her
from cutting herself which would be a
plus I don't know if it'd cure her but
it would be a sneaky way around getting
what I needed and then I'd be able to
get the cane but I highly doubt this is
what it wants me to do is it maybe I
better save this for someone who needs
to sleep well come on now
I'm tasking my brain I'm sniffing up the
right trees but you're not letting me
down in
right places what a bunch of baloney
what a bunch of malarkey oh hey I told
Marcel about the latest delivery but he
hasn't looked at it yet well he will
catch up soon hey Gladys would you do me
a favor sure anything but bring the
coffee to the guard why not I can't do
it because I have to take care of the
children I have other things to do
myself sorry okay well my original idea
was correct then who would have been to
bring the coffee to the guard oh wow
come on but this is what I was supposed
to do how do I supposed to know that it
wasn't supposed to go that way I wanted
to do that maybe you'll want the kid the
cinnamon bunny in the coffee I don't
know well let's try it then I guess I
can't exactly lace it with anything
because it doesn't work out that way
here's your hot hot hot coffee sir ha ha
oh that's much better why did I do that
look at what you did you insane orphan
you did that on purpose now I have
to go and change that's burning like
hell
don't go anywhere you lose what
that was it that was it okay so I gotta
get the key but I need I need a cane to
be able to do that all right so there's
got to be a way to get the cane and
apparently I have a cinnamon bun for
sleeping so maybe if I give the cinnamon
bun to the king he'll fall asleep and
then I won't have to worry about it
anymore
just be able to take what he has I
better save this for someone who needs
to sleep okay so I got to find another
way to get what I need from him and to
be able to do that I've got to be
smarter than I am so I got to figure out
a way to get smarter but markiplier
don't get smarter for nobody nobody at
all
wait oh oh I forgot oh I forgot I had
band-aids oh cool okay I wasn't even
thinking about that one oh thank you you
can have the crayon now I now go I have
to draw okay so I have the crayon which
means that I can combine it with if I
examine it my favorite green crayon
okay combine it with that there we go oh
now it's all fitting together okay my
mind was in the right place I just well
I didn't I didn't you'll connect one dot
that I needed to get so now I can get
the cane which means I can get the key
which means that I can get what I need
and go where I need to go okay come on I
know if I double-click on these I can go
faster come on we got places to go we
got things to see right so now I give
this the King Your Majesty I have a
horse and a castle for you oh that's
beautiful exactly what I dreamt of you
can take my sword now it's yours you
probably needed to walk in whatever but
I'm gonna take it anyway thank you
goodbye okay so this makes a lot more
sense so now should be able to actually
make some progress here I knew that I
wasn't stupid I knew that I must have
been on the right track so if I combine
this this the this time okay this hook
okay so I got what I need now I can use
this hook cane on that to get the keys I
have the key now I can unlock the office
so use this on that door we're good to
go
I feel smart and then we go in and then
we can find the code that we need
somewhere where that is th new testing
to up there's some circled numbers 2 4 7
12 I don't know if that's actually the
code oh wait alarm code right there
good December 17th Oh what oh oh I've
seen this before what does it mean the
pentagram can you're not alone join us
today interview with dr. dear and
working with children tiny tax Marcel
dear in October in November I guess
we're in October testing every day
lovely
okay so I think I got what I needed but
let's explore the rest of the office
because there might be something
horrific here
shame get a typewriter no pictures or
funny riddles got some keys I don't know
what this keys to it might be to be in
one of the basement things so let me
examine this first okay
turn off the alarm from the security
panel and reception the yellow door will
remain open for two minutes until the
alarm deactivates alarm code December
17th equals and then July 25th equals
I'm guessing that's 12 plus 17 equals 29
it's something like that I'll try it a
few combinations was it get to the place
that I need to go doctor used to sit
here and do nothing
I know and then he gave you pills
speaking of which let's take another one
yeah oh is that me why are there so many
intestines even though your eyes are
open you can't understand even though
your eyes are bleeding you can't feel
don't hide what hurts that it hurt you I
don't think that's the best advice thank
you oh that dead girl looks a bit like
me weird huh well I'm sedated and I see
we're stuff but I'm not dead
I can breathe and talk and all the
things a living person does I wouldn't
be too sure about that boo Phil hi
a forgotten girl with no family your cat
will die when the moon arrives what do
you mean okay bye oh oh oh no oh no no
no no Phil please let me out oh boy I
don't really know what this is cool air
comes out of it Oh
Oh God Oh God Oh doc Oh vision taste and
hearing the doctor ate an apple ah this
is bad
do I need to hurry up and do something
because I'm very creeped out right now
should I take a pill
oh man ah I don't think I want to I
don't think I want to very much okay
let's go oh yeah oh god no oh the wind
hole I guess this is my way back owner
Phil knew about this I don't think this
is gonna work out well for you who oh
goodness
Oh gravy oh goodness hi all that rat
really hit his head I should give it a
helmet okay oh no oh no no no no no no
no no no I know I know things I know
things I'll just keep going and going
we'll watch out for that hole in the
ground watch out watch out all righty
then
I can't say that was unexpected oh now
in the basement okay well that was
helpful I was gonna come down here
anyway oh dear where am I now I guess
I'll have to find out huh it didn't hurt
at all enough nothing broken I'm good a
mop that will dance on the floor that
doesn't make much sense a mop that will
dance on the disk see cleaning products
they should clean our toilets there's
only one toilet though got some gloves
there but I can't get them something
alert harp oh here we go
boxes open let me see Oh more pills I
just take them to find my kitty what
about the yellow pills were funding the
red ones why don't you take some
ah okay come on
scraped label mom oh here we go the
patient to five blah is our current
target target responses positive now
expanding to the triggered gland active
planet in dose up to 17 hundred
micrograms change the container so it
looks like an approved variant of duo
teen well that sounds rather
that doesn't that sound sinister I don't
know I don't like the sunlight that's
that's no good
well if I were a witch I could fly away
from here but seems like they're doing
some weird experiments on these kids
oh hey party down here alrighty then
I'll just go upstairs so I found a clue
that they're not being 100% trustworthy
right now it's locked
good thing I grabbed a key Nick hey if
you struggle you will know that it was I
I will be in every corner to make you
suffer and cry if you choose to disobey
your cat's life will be marked no no my
cat is he living oh I fell down the
stairs
Oh oh my dear kitty we'll be together
soon again I promise I miss you my dear
I miss you so much why are you leaving
please don't leave me alone mister
midnight
at the end of the maze Fran this such a
cool game is such a cool game I love
this game this is amazing so I didn't
suffer any damage from falling down the
stairs either I fainted again I wonder
if my dreams are true
the monster won't let me go home but if
I find the maze maybe I can find mr.
midnight yeah it's probably a rational
series of events for a ten-year-old why
not oh where the hell am I now
hello oh that looks lovely but what if I
add in a pill the operating room I don't
want to go inside who is that sir wake
up new boy that don't look good I was
like a lot of rotten flies ooh boy okay
so there's something in there that I
could possibly get let's see what's
going on here
whoa whoa whoa whoa my path to life has
been denied I haven't been born but I
was alive I'm waiting for a mother to
love me that's really sad but frankly
I'm more concerned about the clown horse
thing you can't blame those who are
ignorant but you can't let ignorant
decide life will teach you even through
pain and tears I don't know what any of
that means
and frankly I wouldn't want to so oh oh
oh hi oh no poor girls I hope they get
well soon I don't think they're gonna oh
man oh no it's Morgan its horde its Ward
I don't know what that means either
it's ward what does its ward mean I
don't know what a thwart is get that off
alrighty then hello how are you hello
are you resting did you puke that's
disgusting hope you get well soon but
you're disgusting
oh boy why do you have your brain a hood
it's too warm in there
Oh Oh guess the miters will come and
have some meat this place is fun and
friendly oh so did I did go all the way
around yes I took the new one upstairs
Fran bono I haven't seen her what the
key to the cellar well no and the
doctor's office used to have the key
there
calm down the key is not here I'm sure
I'll let you know if it turns up but you
must calm down yes I'll bring it to you
if I find it alright
goodbye alrighty then my goodness I
can't believe this I'm at the reception
already this is grand but the nurse I
have to get rid of her baby shaken
syndrome that's interesting
ah maybe I should use this donor that I
have negative oh alright then I have to
get rid of her baby with this doughnut
okay well then that's not good Oh oh my
goodness are you okay little baby ah
probably skinny yes I can't remember on
Grace's phone number well maybe you
should because I I've got a lot left the
key holder has no keys phone the key
holder could talk maybe I could put the
key back on the key holder and threw
some at the real bizarro thing she
doesn't see me walking around here like
is this we're actually real Oh the key
was here after all
better ticket that doesn't make any
sense that means that this world that
she's in is actually real so what do I
do
flutter move oh oh okay we're good for
me I did something Ben hold coffee what
happened
No Oh No why did crash well I guess I'm
done with this episode so thank you
everybody so much for watching I really
hope I'm gonna need to do some work too
cover this episode oh man I hate it when
that happens why did it crash ah man
either way thank you everybody so much
for watching sorry to cut the episode on
such a good part but I want to make sure
that I actually get my recording back
because when it crashed the recording
stopped and when it stops it can corrupt
the file so I need to do something so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I'll be back on this game very soon
don't you worry and as always I will see
you in the next video bye what about
these crayons here that's my